this is so much fun it's like one great
person after another comes back to you
and now we've got another great one her
name is elizabeth moss she's an emmy
award-winning actress director and
executive producer thank you very much
you might remember as peggy olson
remember this on the popular tv series
mad men or is june on the hit series
handmade still love that now she's
starring in a new psychological thriller
it's called shining girls which is
adapted from a novel she plays kirby who
works in the archives of the chicago sun
times and is survivor of a brutal
assault by a serial killer okay
kirby teams up with a veteran reporter
to find him
what color were his eyes blue you saw
the whites on both sides yes
what about his nose the eyes aren't
right yet do they look close enough yeah
but i can that's all that we want
a composite isn't a portrait some
stranger won't recognize him off the
street that never happens
what am i doing here we just need enough
details for someone who knows him so
they can recognize the sketch
it won't work
no one knows him
no one knows him where she is with those
blue eyes
very intense elizabeth moss joins us now
in the studio first your character's
name is kirby that's my favorite
daughter's name so every time i was
talking watching you i kept thinking
seeing my own curve but kirby's going
through some stuff yeah i don't want my
kirby to go no
no but this is what's so cool about you
elizabeth jamie just said i remember you
from west wing people say i loved you
and handmaid's tale i loved you as peggy
olsen and now we can add shining girls
to the list this is a very different
role for you yeah it is and that's one
of the reasons i i was so excited about
it you know i was
playing june it was
season three of handmaid's tale and she
was becoming quite the heroine she was
very very strong
and i loved the chance to go in in a
different direction and play somebody
who is very vulnerable so you're a star
but also executive producer uh and you
directed uh scenes including the scene
we just saw and you were around the edge
of your chair saying hey
look at what peggy olson has done you
know i'll cruise now in the badass
category and apparently never takes a
day off
yeah i directed two of the episodes
episodes five and seven out of the eight
but talk about the evolution of that
though i like the point that tony's
making to go from actor to now executive
producer to director is this something
that you always wanted to do no not
really i mean
it was sort of a very organic experience
on handmaid's tale i was a producer and
then i was an executive producer because
i was just doing that kind of work and
then i started directing on it because
that just made sense and then same with
shining girls we have michelle mcclaren
and dana reed two incredibly talented
experienced amazing directors that i
really look up to and we needed a third
and they were like well what about you
do you want to do it so it just kind of
became something
very organic
this character has gone through so much
trauma and loss been through a brutal
attack how did you end up connecting to
her vulnerability that you were just
talking about
i mean i for me the
the analogy of the show was so
brilliantly unique the way that silke
our show runner and writer did it you
know it is a we sort of um it's an
analogy for trauma what kirby is going
through and so i connected with the idea
of no matter what your experience may be
no matter what
may have happened to you in your life i
think everyone has had an experience
where they have felt that their whole
world has turned upside down from one
second to the next whatever that may be
you know even the pandemic i think has
made people go through some something
similar to that so i connected to that
idea i connected to the idea of somebody
who is vulnerable yet strong i don't
believe vulnerability means you're not
strong no i totally agree no listen i
like the name of your production company
love and squalor pictures thank you
what's the message you're sending there
elizabeth lizzie moss
you know we have a very very sort of a
broad taste and we you know
we felt like it was a great
representation of the kind of work that
we want to do we don't want to
pigeonhole us we like to do things that
are light we like to do things that are
dark we like to do things that are
complicated things that are fun and and
we felt like love and squalor was sort
of both sides of the coin
um we also have a lot of literary uh
projects in in development things that
are based on books so we felt like a
literary turn would be nice squall are a
good uh scrabble word
yes very good i still have to look out
look up how to spell it honestly
it's q-u-a with all these different
roles you've had in your career now
you're writing the story of your career
uh a piece at a time when you look back
at the roles you've played is there a
through line that you see
yeah i suppose so um i think the through
line for me is kind of what we were
talking about
characters
women people who are
have two sides to them are strong yet
vulnerable
start in one place and end up in another
like i like to play ten things at once
if possible you know two is not enough
for me so i like to have as much going
on as i possibly can and i think that
that's true of humans as well you know i
think that we have a lot of different
sides to us well you play the
independent woman a lot who's
underestimated yeah yeah and i think
that's kind of the duality there too and
and how you come out of that totally
think of a lot going on handmaid's tale
is going to be and there's going to be a
new season yeah uh i'm not caught up
with the latest season but i've seen a
lot of them
for people who are caught up and are
wanting to know what's gonna happen what
can you share about this next season oh
my gosh um
we are halfway through filming it right
now so it's very early days for me to
sort of encapsulate what it is but i
think that um june is obviously dealing
with a lot as usual
uh and uh it's about how do you deal
with freedom if it's handed to you
and you when you wanted it when you
wanted it so badly yeah is it what you
thought it would be
um and can she ever sort of come back
from her experiences in in gilead yeah
just when i think you guys can't take
this in in another direction they do
they do thank you bravo to you and
congrats continued success thank you
continue soaring lizzie moss we're so
glad you're here thank you so happy to
be here
her show shining girls premieres this
friday on apple tv plus and we are
cheering her on we'll be right back